قال وزير الخارجيه الصينيه شين على
الجانبين الصيني والياباني اتباع التوافق
الذي وصفه بالمهم لقاده البلدين وتعزيز
العلاقات الثنائيه لازاله التدخلات
والتغلب على الصعوبات واضاف الوزير الصيني
بعد محادثات اجراها مع نظيره الياباني في
العاصمه الصينيه بجين ان التعايش السلمي
والتعاون الودي هما الخياران الصحيحان
الوحيدان للعلاقات الصينيه اليابانيه
وبشان قضيه التجسس التي تخص مواطنا
يابانيا في الصين اكد شينج ان الصين
ستتعامل معها وفقا للقانون واشار الوزير
الصيني الى ان الولايات المتحده استخدمت
اساليب البلطجه لقمع صناعه اشباه الموصله
اليابانيه بوحشيه وهي الان تكرر حيلها
القديمه ضد الصين حسب قوله من جانبه قال
وزير الخارجيه الياباني ان العلقه
اليابانيه لديها امكانات كبيره للتنميه